Okay, this is Andy Row. So what I've got here,
you get rack links, it's falling apart.
He's a TV producer in London and in his office where we reached him,
he's got these very special metal balls.
This is the original prototype of the golden ball is lovely and shiny.
It's very light.
Each one's the size of maybe an orange or a tangerine or a tennis ball,
painted gold and it makes it very satisfying.
Clunk when it closes and that clung,
that is the sound of betrayal
because Andy has used these balls to bring out the worst in people to show how
ugly and conniving we can be,
but also how wonderful and if you think you know about all that,
then you could win big on golden balls.
Okay, so we're talking about a game show called of course golden bulls.
Andy was one of the executive producers did pretty well. We were really,
really proud of golden balls. Ran for three years in the UK,
maybe 300 episodes in quite short space. The title of the show, yes.
It was such fun.
And it is fun because in many ways it is just a normal game shot.
But I would argue there is more going on here. In fact,
I'm about to argue that because there is a moment in one of those 300 episodes,
one moment did I just cannot shake.
Cause you remember the first time I showed you this, this clip, I was totally,
totally, totally thrown by it because what's about to happen?
Is it two guys with totally different moral philosophies are about to go yes
with some fascinating results in this story. In fact inspired the whole show.
It did look today, three different smack downs,
all that somehow smack down.
Not In the way that you would expect different people, different dreams,
different worldviews, all going,
we're calling the show what's left when you're right,
which is genius. You'll find that out later.
It will ultimately make sense. Perfect sense, I think. Yeah. Later for now.
Can we get the golden balls happening? Yeah. Um,
all I can remember was that, um, all right.
So before we get to the moment that I want to talk about,
we kind of have to walk a few paces to sort of lay the foundation,
which is that we have to explain the rules of this game, which are uh,
you can all describe golden balls in a sentence to anybody.
It makes no sense whatsoever. But I will try and simplify.
So basically there are all these early rounds where people are mining money,
losing money, cheating each other, lying, uh, strategizing,
voting one another off the show.
I'm going to skip all that because it is in the last five minutes that all hell
breaks loose.
It's that classic shout at the Tele Moment where you're sitting at home going,
[inaudible] can't believe you just did that because basically the whole game
culminates with a face off, you know, face a very straightforward choice.
Two players sit on opposite sides of a table with this host. Between them. Yeah.
Jasper, Charisse,
his name man whose head is as shiny and smooth as a golden ball itself.
I know I just edited in someone laughing at my own joke that just happened.
In any case,
when you get to this moment at the end of the game where there's two people
facing each other in the spotlight, it's all gone quiet. Okay?
In that moment,
their hearts are racing because they've got to make this key choice,
which is not just about money, although there is money on the line. Of course,
it is a choice that will reveal who they really are,
not who we all are. Okay. What humanity. So we'll be laid bare.
This may be true, but why don't we just just lay out the rules themselves?
Sorry, got a little carried away. No, no. All right. So in the final round,
each of the contestants get two golden balls and they are the most important
golden balls of the game. One ball says split.
You each have a golden ball with the word split written inside.
The other ball says steal. You're both have a ball with the word steal.
Written inside split. Like say you and I are playing, right? Yup.
If I choose to split ball, what I'm really saying is that this Jackpot,
whatever it is, say it's 3,200 pounds. Sterling. Okay. Yeah.
I'm saying I want to split it with you. Let's just split it in half,
50 50 even Steven, I'm a good guy.
Now if you also choose split, then we split it.
You get half, I get half. Everybody's happy.
The feeling of kind of joy that everybody had when it was a split was fantastic.
You know, both going home with 1,600 pounds.
Okay, so that's one outcomes. One of four outcomes I believe.
Cause obviously there are other ways this could go cause one or both of the
contestants can choose steel. And what steel basically says is,
forget sharing. I want to take the whole thing for myself.
And if we both decide that if you both choose the steal ball,
we both screw each other and it cancels out.
You leave today's game with what you came with.
Nothing. Nobody gets anything. That's the thing. I like what he says. Nothing.
Nothing with a little bit of contempt, deservedly. Yes.
Two greedy people deserve nothing here. Nothing except each other.
Exactly nothing. Right? So if we both decide to split, it is mutually good.
If we both decide to steal it is mutually bad. Yeah.
No where things get thorny is it, say you got a mismatch,
like one person chooses split, the other person chooses steal.
Now in that scenario, the person who chose Split,
the nice guy or gal gets nothing.
Whereas the person who chose steal the conniving duplicitous bastard everything.
So you you if you steal and the other person is kind,
then you walk away with the money. Yeah. I mean by the way,
this is the classic prisoner's dilemma from Game Theory,
which some people may recognize,
but the basic idea is that there is an incentive to share. Cause if you split,
you split, each person takes half.
But there is also an incentive to lie because if I can convince you to share the
money and I turn around and shaft you, well then I get more money that way.
And the best part about this game for our purposes is that before the
contestants make a choice,
jasper the host gets them to talk to each other about what they're going to do.
Okay. Before I asked you to choose.
I think you have some talking to do to each other. Alright, so watch this one.
You got a young blonde girl facing off with uh,
a larger gentleman with a mustache older. Yep. Yeah.
And the Jackpot is a hundred thousand pounds. Stephen.
I just taught my word puppy dog tears and they were real fears.
And you are genuinely going to split that. I, I'm going to split this
50,000. Um, I'm just on. It's unbelievable. 50,000.
She's crying at this point. She's kind of adorable. I like her.
She's like an innocent.
If I stole off you every single pestle that would run over and Lynch me,
there was no way I could. I mean, everyone who knew me would just be disgusted.
If I stop. See how he's gripping his legs, he's up to something.
[inaudible] I can look you straight in the eye and tell you I am going split.
I swear, don't you? I'm going to split. Okay.
This is serious money, Sarah. Steve,
choose either the split or the steal ball. Now
hold it up. We'll go on with 50 grand each. I promise you that
moment it's your
[inaudible]
chose split. She chose steal the, the nice girl was a thief,
a nice girl with bad. Every time I see this,
it totally breaks my heart cause a guy just falls under the desk.
He's got his head in his hands. He's just destroyed. David, I'm so sorry.
Commiserations
look, look at her. She's looking away. She can't look at him.
He's falling into a slump on the table. It's just awful. It's evil, isn't it?
It's such a good little game. And here's the thing.
If you analyze all the outcomes, which social scientists have done,
what you see is that a majority of the time,
something like what I just showed you happens competition.
People get up there and they're like,
I swear I will never say I am a good person.
Over and over they say, I am not the kind of person that's gonna Cheat you.
And then they do it.
[inaudible]
stab him in the back and he's her grandma's policemen. And here's my theory.
It's not that they're mean people,
it's that they don't want to be that guy slumped on the table.
They don't want to be the sucker.
The fear of being the sucker far overwhelms the desire to do good to their
fellow contestants. There's something wrong with this program.
The obvious thing to do is to share.
You managed to wheedle your way into the approximate possession of a fortune and
all you have to do is agree to split it.
But what if you don't trust the person across the table from you?
Would you still share it? That's, that's interesting. Yeah.
Let's suppose I happened to be,
I'm introduced to a person named snidely whiplash and he has an enormous oiled
mustache and he's wearing a cape and he has this habit of rubbing his hands
malevolently and his eyes are twitching and his eyes are twitching.
So I'm sitting out here and I'm waiting to share with this guy. See,
it's in a situation like that. That's when it's a real test that's in this game.
So what do you do if you don't want to be a sucker and you're not sure you can
trust the person across the table.
There's no good answer to that.
But then hi. Hi. Is this nick? It is. This brings us to the moment of question.
We ran into this guy, my name's Nick Corrigan. I work for Media Academy,
Cardiff based in Wales.
So, uh, nick runs a not for profit in Wales and um,
right away when you talk to him, you notice two things. He loves whales.
It's the most beautiful country in the world. And He loves game shows. Yes.
What was your first one? When I was about 17,
he was on a quiz show and I won a book.
Nick has since been on by his count, 44 game shows. Whoa.
It's one 43 of them. He says, uh, he's,
when I'm boat two on a house full of stuff, trips to various places.
This is like what he does. And when he first encountered golden balls,
he noticed the same miserable pattern that we all noticed,
which is like the nice people get up there. They say, let's share,
let's do it. We can be in this together.
And then every time I'm there we're just shafted.
But then nick got an idea. How did you get that idea?
I think I was probably um,
swimming.
I get all my greatest ideas and assuming it was only when I went back and had a
cup of tea,
as everybody in Wales obviously drinks tea with your lump of coal right next to
you, you pack, you're a little pet. Coal.
Coal is very important to Wales of when I got back I thought actually it can't
fail.
[inaudible]
so nick makes it onto the show, mix it to the last round,
welcome back to golden bowls and he finds himself sitting across the table from
a man named Ibrahim who, two of them or a study in contrast.
Nick is tall, he's got really intense eyes, feathered hair.
Ibrahim is short and bald and looks kind of like a mini telly.
Savalas Ibrahima Nick, you now face a very straightforward choice. But yes,
for the host lays out the scenario. They are there,
they're competing for 14,000 pounds.
They have to decide to split or steal and now we get to the good part. Now,
keep in mind as you listen to this, that almost a hundred percent of the time,
what happens in this moment is one person looks at the other and says,
I promise you I will choose the split ball. We'll share it. Share it together.
Yeah. That's what they say. Nick takes a very different approach.
Abraham,
I want you to trust me 100% I'm going to pick the steal ball.
Sorry. You're going to, I'm going to choose the steal ball. You're gonna take.
I want you to do split and I promise you that I will split the money with you.
We'll offer you took a steal. Yeah, you can take steel. Yeah,
I'm going to take split. Yeah,
so you take the money and I was supposed to with you after the show. Yeah.
Okay.
There was, there was out to panic in the studio. Kisses whole idea was like,
I'm not even going to pretend I'm not going to steal it and then I'll meet you
on a corner after the television show you the half of it.
[inaudible] that's ridiculous. Older researchers started running around going,
what's he doing? Can this be done? There was panic.
I promise you I'll do that. If, if you do steal, we both walk away with nothing.
I'm telling you 100% I'm going to do it. I appreciate that. Right?
I'll give you another alternative.
Why don't we just both pick split? I'm not gonna pick split.
I'm going to steal Abraham. Honestly, 100 that I'm gonna Steal.
It's in your nature to steal. No, are you?
I'm honest and I'm gonna tell you I am. That's one thing I'm going to steal.
If you do split, then I will split the money. Can't see myself today, man. Okay,
well I'm going to steal so we're going to leave with nothing.
Where's your brains coming from
thought work at?
I know that I'm a decent guy and I will spend the money with you. Well,
we should just buy them. No, I'm going to do steal
this argument went on and on. [inaudible] Riley, he actual argument,
not the edited version. Online went for 45 minutes. There was a name calling.
There were threats and over those 45 minutes there was an interesting shift.
Nick says that the audience began to turn on him.
The audience behind were booing me, which I get because as I was watching it,
I mean initially it seems like a really cool, clever strategy,
but then you realize as it goes down that he's being kind of at the ass.
Like he's not giving the other guy a choice.
He's actually kind of bullying him no matter what he said.
I was not budging for the fact and it may intransigence just if you're rage at
him.
Did you ever actually like hate him or actually yes, I did hate him.
Yes. Oh yes. Yes I did.
This is Ebrahim April Him who signed? I'm a market trader.
I'll work on flea markets. He sells textiles in London.
It took us forever to track him down. Months. You found me at last,
but at the hight hemophilia because he couldn't be, he couldn't,
you couldn't negotiate with him. There was no negotiation.
I was saying to him like if I give you my word that I'm going to split,
if I gave you my word, now let me, let me tell you what my word means. Okay.
My father once said to me, a man who doesn't keep his word, he's not a man.
He's not worth nothing. Not Worth it. Not worth a dollar. I agree,
Abraham, I'm going to steal it so you've got the choice.
That was the point where I was like, nick, give the guy a chance at least. Okay,
well we lost the lost.
Then they walked away with no money because you're an idiot. No
need it.
Wait, wait.
This can go on all night and these people have got to get up for breakfast.
Nick choose split or steal
and right before they have to make their decision, it seems that Ibrahim Caves,
maybe nick warmed down and he's like, fine,
you choose steal to split. Hopefully you'll share the money.
Well, I'll tell you what I'm going to cover with you. Okay, I'm done.
I promise you,
you cannot change your balls. Now
split or steal.
They both turn over their balls. Ibrahim, as we suspected, chose split. Oh,
I felt I had no alternative. And Nick also chose Split.
Yeah. Congratulations. You're both split an ACC
[inaudible]
the whole game. He swore he was gonna Steal. But then he ends up splitting.
Do you think that he was lying the whole time and always intended to share?
We could've changed his mind at the last, second, whatever the case.
Here's why his strategy was so brilliant. Oh Shit. Oh Shit. Oh,
taken aback when we asked Ebrahimi like if nick hadn't been deployed that crazy
strategy, would you have still split?
Because that's what you were saying to him the whole time that you're gonna
split it. You're gonna share the money. Would you have still done it?
No, not at all. Not at all. Oh, I was always going to steal.
I was never gonna Split. Never really? Never really.
I was never gonna Split. Why? Why, why?
The reason being if I split and the other guy stills, okay, nothing.
[inaudible] both of us walk away with nothing than someone. Um, what's the word?
Embarrass me to a certain extent. Didn't want to be the sucker.
And then I asked him like, what about that speech with your dad? You know,
that's the one that Kinda got me.
My father once said to me, a man who doesn't keep his work, he's not mine.
It cannot. No. Can I just jump in the bat that yeah.
[inaudible] I never met him. I, I,
my mother brought me up.
Me and my brother and my sister and I'll never ever met my father
that you made that up. Yeah,
I'm afraid so you made that up?
Yeah. Yeah. I'll feel sorry you on a film once
and it always stuck with me. I'll be able to use that one day.
I've never been a good boy.
[inaudible]
I think that is the real victory here.
Like nick got a guy who's never intending to share the money,
whose whole philosophy was like, don't trust anybody. Don't cross no one.
He got that guy to be good against his will and that guy,
thanks him for it. He did call me to certain extent,
but he calmed me into 7,000 pounds
and nick for his part is also grateful to have the money so he can give it to
charity, run a children's charity.
I do all the health and safety and all the fundraising.
Is that connected in any way to your multiple appearances on game shows? Yes,
it is. Yes. Directly. Yes.
It's silly surprise. I do cause it's a very [inaudible].
Nick is doing his good works. We will take a brief break and be right back.
Hi, this is Brian Crawford calling from wonderful Littleton, Colorado.
Radiolab is supported by signature theatre presenting three time Pulitzer Prize
winner,
Edward [inaudible] at home at the zoo home-life and the zoo story directed by
Laila Noga Bauer with jolts of brutality and Alby signature dark humor.
This seminal work explores the love and cruelty we inflict on each other.
Every day begins January 30th tickets and more@signaturetheater.org.